another gym day with Jordan sup guys
that's it not gonna be the greatest day
ever
doesn't matter like a visible a super
clarity muscle like my name is Gary
these table [ __ ] I've been
telling you I'm triple a pedigree the
meaning are special my specialty
I'm putting the works on I'm Jerry
[ __ ] workouts pissing me off
yeah that's when you know it's good but
it pisses you off
it's good what's going on in this Sunday
a lot going on what is good hey Jay just
turned 30
that was good um just grind it long
they're kind of like work out a family
Sunday oh I think you crazy just uh one
remind everybody actions louder than
words business life parenting politics
all of it it's your actions everybody's
getting lazy with comments I think it's
enough you got do doing always wins
four three two one good
[Music]
nice job sixes so now we're just talking
about to do some weird push-ups on this
ball but anyway and I just kind of
looked at myself and I'm like happy with
the progress and I just said seven days
a week day in and day out day in and day
out seven days a week and it's so
interesting to me this is the exact
episode of daily be to pass on to your
Fitness friends so many of them get it
when it comes to being in the gym but
then they think a couple of the
shirtless selfies on Instagram are
enough to like build their business and
they're not putting in that seven days a
week day in and day out I didn't realize
that people thought it wasn't true and
that's the truth and that's the truth
for so many of you watch or now didn't
think it was true you didn't think was
true that they were 15 16 hours a day
you thought they were hyperbolized and
they were eight or nine you didn't
realize that every minute was something
you didn't realize that it's every day
always forever and and not that this is
for everybody but it speaks to it surely
has eliminated the luck thing and what I
don't think people realize is this has
been going on every day for the last
seven years at this pace every day day
in and day out work that's it and then
there's really just nothing else there's
your talent your strategy and the work
you put in those are the three pillars
right you've got your talent and for
them 99.9% of us we can only maximize
our talent right just like some people
just naturally have that some people can
naturally just sell some people can
actually just put the ball in hoop
there's your talent and if you put in
the work you can maximize that there's
the work which is the most controllable
it's the thing that we all control I
could have not come in the gym this
Sunday morning or I can like it just the
work you could stay up another hour and
work on your copy the work you've put in
Jordan on your social since you've come
with me not just the work either do it
or you don't when I bust your chops
about Instagram first couple days this
year you you said did you do it you're
like yeah I go no you didn't you did one
photo not three right right see the
looks just work and in this strategy
right if you have the wrong strategy if
you're if you're putting into all your
efforts on Google+ right now you're
wrong if you're if you're putting all
your efforts in the gym of stuff that's
not helping you because you don't have a
trained professional or you didn't get
good advice you're not gonna win it as
much there was were three things that I
want everybody to think about you got
your natural talent don't be crippled by
what you can't do worry about what you
can do you've got your work it's the
number one thing I push because it's the
most controllable and then you've got
the strategy that's the part that we
need to kind of expand on here in 2017
that's why I talk about day trading
attention when I was warming up it's
like you think it's just good to mess
attention is that we said like yeah I
mean it is it's like then you know how
to deploy it so those are three pillars
[Music]
I'd rather do it on my own no one else
can feel a my time is moving back in not
stay
most people with the smile on display